bonsoir bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition de votre journal d'information
locale et au sommaire de ce mardi 21
octobre la pépinière d'entreprise de 50
ans niveline va mal très mal après
l'annonce de la cessation de paiement
les attaques politiques se multiplient
la droite accuse notamment l'ancienne
équipe dirigeante socialiste de lourde
faute à morpa la ville vient d'organiser
le premier Grenel des associations
objectif installer durablement le
dialogue avec ceux qui font vivre la
commune et surtout éviter la situation
de blocage rencontrée avec le club de
tennis à la fin de l'été la mauvaise
gestion de la structure avait poussé le
conseil municipal à reprendre la main
taxes sur le diesel péage gratuit
sécurité sur les routes l'actualité ne
manque pas pour l'association 40
millions d'automobilistes invité Daniel
kerot son président l'association se
revend indique première représentante
des automobilistes auprès des pouvoirs
publics et du secteur économique de la
route les surveillants de la maison
d'arrêt de boisars manifester une
nouvelle fois ce matin devant les portes
de l'établissement sous l'impulsion du
syndicat SLP Force Ouvrière pour
dénoncer la multiplication des
agressions dont le personnel est victime
la semaine passée cinq d'entre eux ont
été blessés à la suite d'une altercation
avec un détenu bilan un écassé un
poignet fracturé ils subissent également
depuis quelques semaines des agressions
en dehors de l'établissement les
surveillants dénoncent également un
manque d'effectifs selon le syndicat SLP
Force Ouvrière donc il manquerait 40
agents au quotidien et cette semaine pas
moins de 75 personnes en raison de
mutation il aura notre ministre qui est
passé il y a pas très longtemps faire
des annonces sur la maison d' bois d'Arc
et en même temps visiter l'établissement
mais on va toujours rien venir rien
venir au niveau des effectifs justement
donc nous on demande des effectifs très
rapidement sauf que des effectifs bah
c'est pareil les collègues il faut les
former faut faire des recrutements donc
c'est pas pour tout de suite faut
compter au moins un an facilement il y a
8 mois d'école déjà euh donc on est
parti pour durer encore très longtemps
comme ça et les collègues en PE flu ils
sont au bout ils voi ils voient plus
leur famille j'ai un collègue qui me
disait l'autre jour là en 3 mois il a vu
deux fois sa femme propos recueilli par
Anthony re selon ce syndicat 18
agressions se sont produites au sein de
la maison d'arrêt au cours des 6
premiers mois de l'année 2014 un match
de football qui tourne au pugila
dimanche le stade de René Rousseau au
clés soubois l'équipe locale s'est
opposée physiquement à celle de voisin
le breteneux l'entraîneur vcinois a reçu
un coup de point au visage alors qu'il
tentait de calmer la situation une
enquête policière est en cours Promopole
est en cessation de paiement nous en
parlions hier déjà la pépinière
d'entreprise est en grande difficulté
dans la soirée une réunion d'information
a eu lieu à Montini le Bretonneux Hotman
naserou le nouveau président a invité
les entreprises LOCATAIRES du site pour
éclaircir cette situation Floren parfet
Catherine zulato et Lodi moine pour ce
dossier les visages sont soucieux plus
ou moins inquiets ils sont nombreux à
s'être déplacés pour en savoir plus sur
le sort de Promopole donc évidemment il
y a toujours les beau rien ne change
mais il é important pour moi que vous
ayez en tête aujourd'hui une procédure
juridique double procédure juridique
souve la société ne fait plus face à ces
échéances depuis le mois de février
dernier avec 2,2 million d'euros de
dette la situation est plus que
compliquée une procédure collective est
engagée la pépinière va être placée sous
la protection du tribunal de commerce et
un administrateur va être nommé
président depuis juin 2014man N a évoqué
la possibilité d'un redressement
judiciaire pas de dépôt de bilan selon
lui la justice devrait se saisir du
dossier au mois de novembre jusque là
rien ne devrait changer pour les
entrepreneurs de
Promopole en ce qui concerne de notre
avenir et la situation actuelle bah
effectivement moi je l'ai pas vu venir
je l'ai quasiment appris il y a quelques
jours moi je suis ici depuis
1992 donc on a vu malheureusement une
dégradation depuis 5 6 ans et sans
aucune intervention extérieure
finalement merci d'avoir organisé cette
réunion ent pleine de franchise donc
maintenant on va attendre la
prochaineance qui mi novembre j'y crois
pas beaucoup
égard à ce qui vient d'être dit je ne
vois pas comment les choses ben quelle
solution finale mauvaise gestion selon
Hotman nasrou une grande partie du
problème est dû au site de trappe en
2008 Promopole est nommé titulaire de la
délégation du service public pour
construire le site des murziers
aujourd'hui le déficit est de 1,8
million
d'euros financiè qui on commencé à se
manifester à partir du moment où où
200920 donc avec l'ouverture du du site
des meurciers ça c'est un fait comptable
je découvre un certain nombre de
décisions qui me semblent surprenantes
ou en tout cas pas favorable à l'intérêt
de la société donc je peux pas vous les
détailler puisque effectivement ça sera
la justice de dire ce qu'il en est
réellement je pense que l'argent public
quand il est investi doit aller
réellement au profit du plus grand
nombre et j'ai le sentiment que sur un
certain nombre de décisions qui ont été
prises à Promopole ça n'a pas été le cas
des pares qui ont fait réagir gu
Malandin maire de trappe à cette période
le président de Promopole était Jeany
Gendron élu Parti communiste à trappe
aujourd'hui délégué au développement
économique de la ville il y a un déficit
important de la société Promopole 40 %
de ce déficit vient de la DSP mais c'est
l'engagement c'était l'engagement de de
Promopole quand ils ont répondu à
l'appel d'ofre ils étaient pas obligés
de répondre voilà et les autres qui ont
répondu avaient aussi avait aussi
pendant plusieurs années toutes les DSP
c'est comme ça pendant plusieurs années
l'amortissement de la construction du
bâtiment qui qui joue sur qui joue sur
les comptes quoi donc donc là on est
conforme à l'engagement qui a été pris
et signé par par toutes les parties hein
quand le nouveau président mrou parle de
erreur importantes de gestion des fautes
graves entraînant un risque de conflit
d'intérêt l'affaire va êtreun aucun
aucun commentaire sur ce genre de
déclaration les sites merisier et tores
seront repris par la ville de trappe la
situation de Promopole devrait évoluer
rapidement un premier avis du tribunal
de commerce sera donné le 15
novembre économie toujours retour sur
les 15 ans du club face nous étions la
semaine dernière à leur cérémonie
d'anniversaire parmi les invités des
partenaires mais également et des
personnes soutenues qui sont venu
témoigner de leur expérience claire
Cambier et William H pour les images
mais on sent au sein des du beau monde
au théâtre de Saint-Quentin en Yveline
jeudi dernier préfet chef d'entreprise
dirigeants locaux mais la star de la la
soirée rester le club face l'association
de la Fondation agir contre l'exclusion
fêté ces 15 ans l'occasion de remercier
les partenaires et de rencontrer des
personnes soutenues par le club comme
Ayou en échec scolaire il a été suivi
pendant un an
j'ai intégré un lycée
en en études général lycée Milie de
bretaille à
Montini et j'espère continuer travailler
pour
pas pour pas retomber dans l'échec c'est
tout
découverte du monde professionnel
soutien le club face est également au
retour vers l'emploi Ron n qu'un bac en
poche il a enchaîné les petits boulots
avant de trouver un poste de technicien
Télécom je intégré dans dans
l'équipe je suis monté très vite en
compét formations des certifications
et
maintenant ma carrière évoluer quo
j'étais assz réservé on va
direainant ça va beaucoup
mieux pour l'aider dans ses démarches
Pascal Le Gendre son parrain l'a
conseillé et soutenu notamment par des
stages dans sa société un moyen de
laisser de la place à l'humain sur son
lieu de travail j'ai l'impression
d'apporter quelque chose et c'est
effectivement ça ça donne du sens au
management ça donne du du sens à ce que
je peux apporter dans le travail en 15
ans 500 personnes ont bénéficié d'un
parrainage sur 1200 accompagné plus de
la moitié ont retrouvé un emploi
impossible sans le soutien du tissu
local mesure des années on a eu une
dynamique qui s'est accr accrue au
niveau des des entreprises
puisqueaujourd'hui on a une soixantaine
d'entreprises impliqué dans les actions
du club le club F soutient également des
structures d'aide locale et favorise la
diversité en
entreprise je reçois présent Daniel
kerot bonsoir êes le président de 40
millions d'automobilistes avec 320000
adhérents vous vous présenter comme un
interlocuteur privilégié du gouvernement
et du secteur économique de la route
trois missions protéger les intérêts des
automobilistes les conseiller aussi et
puis proposer des solutions pour
l'environnement ou encore la sécurité
routière l'actualité ne manque pas
gratuité des péag campagne de
sensibilisation aussi de la prévention
routière qui a été lancée pour ses
vacances une campagne plus softe vous le
verrez tout à l'heure et puis il y a
aussi ce baromètre d'expertise
automobile que vous avez publié on va
commencer par la taxe sur le gazol pour
remplacer l'écotaxe le gouvernement a
décidé d'augmenter de quelques centimes
ce carburant la hausse ne devait
concerner que les automobilistes
finalement les poids lourds également
les députés ont adopté la mesure lundi
soir avec 40 millions d'automobilistes
vous étiez plutôt remonté contre cette
décision du gouvernement là le fait que
les poils lour ils soit aussi associés
vous êtes un peu moins en colère ce soir
je dirais que c'est une taxe de plus
pour les automobilistes qui sont déjà
soumis à beaucoup beaucoup de taxes euh
donc c'est vrai que nous
sommes souvent amenés à nous exprimer
sur le sujet nous n'aimons pas que on
augmente sans arrêt les taxes parce que
c'est une réduction du pouvoir rouler
pour les automobilistes mais ça va conc
aussi les poids lourds donc finalement
il n'y aura pas que les automobilistes
il y a aussi ces entreprises qui sont
concernées oui mais compense en tant que
40 millions d'automobilistes moi je
parle des automobilistes et je m'exprime
en leur nom qu'ils ne sont pas très
contents vous demandez la suspension de
cette taxe pour être très cl oui nous
disons qu'il y a déjà trop de taxes
c'est vrai que en ce moment le carburant
est est plutôt en réduction mais il faut
regarder aussi ce qui se passe dans le
monde puisque nous sommes en Europe le
le continent le plus taxé en terme de de
de carburant si vous regardez l'Amérique
du Nord he le prix du carburant est
pratiquement la moitié prix de ce qui se
passe en Europe alors nous on a même
regardé je dirais les les pays où il y
avait le plus fort tau de croissance si
on s'aperçoit dans le monde que les pays
qui ont plus fortau de croissance c'est
là où les carburants sont moins chers on
peut imaginer une mobilisation des
automobilistes de la même manière qu'on
avait pu voir les bonnet rouges en
Bretagne qui ont fait plier le
gouvernement et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le gazole qui est
taxé au départ c'était l'écotaxe c'est
toujours difficile de mobiliser la
grande masse des automobilistes nous
nous agissons plutôt sur comme témoin de
l'opinion publique l'opinion publique a
une action auprès des élus puisque les
élus sont très sensibles à l'opinion
publique notre capacité c'est de
mobiliser l'opinion publique nous
l'avons réussi il y a pas longtemps
quand nous nous sommes élevés contre les
80 km/h généralisés sur le réseau hors
autoroute et là le gouvernement nous a
entendu parce que cette mesure éta
rejeté par 90 % de la population des
automobilistes vous parlez du
gouvernement justement est-ce que vous
êtes inquiet des différentes décisions
en tout cas de la façon dont le
gouvernement s'y prend je pense aussi au
au quak sur la gratuité des autoroutes
sur le le weekend c'est seolen royale la
ministre de l'écologie qui qui fait
cette annonce avant d'être recadré
quelques heures plus tard par Manuel
valalls alors c'est vrai que l'annonce
de seggolen royale était pour le moins
surprenante mais elle a quand même eu un
mérite elle a eu un mérite de relancer
un débat auquel nousbat a pas duré
longtemps he au bout de quelques heures
c'était déjà terminé oui mais on a quand
même beaucoup débattu de prix des
autoroutes puisque ça fait 10 ans que
les autoroutes sont dans le secteur
libéral et que depuis 10 ans les
autoroutes ont toujours augmenté chaque
année de plus que l'inflation donc nous
nous disons il y a eu un trop perçu
render l'argent donc c'est ça peut se
faire par un blocage des des des prix et
voir une diminution des prix vous auriez
souhaité vous souhaitez toujours cette
gratuité justement la gratuité c'est un
élément mais surtout une réduction des
tarifs une réduction des tarifs au moins
un blocage parce qu'il y a eu un trop
perçu rendez-nous l'argent et vous
expliquez que ce serait aussi une mesure
de sécurité routière parce que ces
routes sont sûres s les autoroutes sont
les les réseaux les plus sécurisés en
France d'ailleurs c'est pas nouveau hein
la gratuité de l'autoroute parce qu'on a
eu l'air de prendre ses golden royal
pour une illuminée ce qui n'est pas le
cas parce que finalement aujourd'hui il
a quand il y a des épreuves
motocyclistes sur le circuit duument qui
est pas très loin de chez nous et bien
les sociétés d'autoroute décrètent que
ces weekends là les phag seront gratuits
h vous le souhaitez c'est une des
mesures que vous auriez souhaité mettre
en place comment vous pouvez réussir à
influencer avoir une importance à peser
sur les décisions du gouvernement dans
quelle mesure vous réussissez à vous
faire entendre vous avez donné l'exemple
des 80 kmh tout à l'heure 40 millions
d'automobilistes est très à le mérite je
dirais d'avoir pu trouver auprès des
médias la capacité à présenter les
automobilistes donc à chaque fois qu'il
se passe quelque chose qui concerne les
automobilistes ou l'automobile nous
sommes appelés à répondre donc nous on
nous entendons beaucoup dans les médias
nous avons beaucoup de d'automistes qui
nous soutiennent et donc les les les les
élus sont sensibles à l'opinion publique
donc comme ça nous est que les élus vous
sollicitent aussi directement parce que
vous les interp par la voie des médias
entendu nous nousous nous travaillons
aussi avec les élus les sénateurs les
députés nous sommes auditionnés et nous
avons des bénévoles qui travaillent ces
sujets et des permanents qui [__] sujet
on n'est pas que dans la contestation on
est dans la proposition combien de
permanents comment ça fonctionne
justement nous avons cinq permanents
nous avons un nombre bénévoles qui
travaillent dans les commissions
commission juridique commission
technologique sociologie des usagers de
la route avec vous voyez donc nous
sommes organisés et nous sommes pas que
dans la contestation mais dans la
proposition votre autre mission aussi
vos autres missions protéger conseiller
les automobilistes et vous avez publié
avec l'association le baromètre de
l'expertise automobile en matière de
sinistre vol accident incendie
intempérique collision département des
ivelines ne figure pas en bonne place 2è
position en France avec plus presque
26000 cas comment vous avez établi ce ce
classement on a on a fait ça avec les
les experts du BCA et qui ont forcément
toutes les statistiques de vol de de
comment dirais-je de sinistralité pour
les automobilistes donc nous avons
établi ce baromètre qu'on publiera
régulièrement et effectivement si on
regarde les voitures les plus volées ce
sont en premier la la Smart forout et en
2è la Clio 1 et pour pour les véhicules
les plus vandalisés c'est la BMW X5 et
après c'est la midi faites pas forcément
de la publicité ce soir c'était dans
quel but ce palmarès ben c'est pour
informer les automobilistes mais chose
intéressante c'est que 3 jours après
qu'on a publié le baromètre des voitures
les plus volées monsieur caseneu
ministre deintérieur a lancé un grand
plan pour lutter contre les filières de
vol de voiture voyez donc ça on a été
entendu et je pense d'ailleurs que
depuis que Monsieur CNU est à
l'intérieur on a le sentiment qu'il est
un peu plus à l'écoute de l'ensemble des
a autobiliste et des citoyens on va
parler à présent avec vous de la
nouvelle campagne de l'association de la
prévention routière je le disais tout à
l'heure les sujets ne manquent pas
l'actualité ne manque pas pour les
automobiliste il y a un changement de
ton évident fini les images trashes il
est maintenant question d'instant de
bonheur regardez l'un de ces
spots
on a tous une bonne raison de rester
vivant association prévention routière
et vous quelle est votre bonne raison
l'association Prévention Routière qui
change donc de mode de communication
fini les images choc il y a aussi des
affiches plus une communication sur les
réseaux sociaux qui qui complètent donc
cette campagne de communication votre
avis c'est une bonne méthode je trouve
que cette campagne est intéressante et
intelligente parce que finalement nous
vivons tellement dans les images de
violence que pour une fois si on arrive
à des images plus douces c'est là que ça
va être remarqué ça veut dire que les
images violentes les images réelles
d'accident ça ne fonctionne pas
forcément sur les automobilistes vous
regardez les médias vous regardez la
télé sans arrêt des images de violence
on est tellement habitué à la violence y
compris sur les accidents que à la
limite personne ne fait plus attention
si on a des images douces voir
humoristique peut-être que la tenenstion
sera là et je crois qu'on est tous pour
pour la sensib isation puisquon est
arrivé à un niveau tel de
répression qu'il faut faire autre chose
et la sensibilisation la prévention
l'éducation c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important et ça ça va
participer on va écouter les ctinois à
présent nous sommes allés leur demander
leur avis sur cette cette nouvelle
campagne de communication sur à la fin
de ces images trashes pour la prévention
routière
oui oui il faut marquer les esprits donc
voilà faire peur aux gens non faut faut
responsabiliser les gens et puis montrer
la réalité je pense qu'elle doiv être
pour choquer le le téléspectateur pour
que il prennent conscience des des
dangers pas forcément je pense ça nous
touche mais après voilà quand on voit
l'image après on se dit pas tiens je
vais arrêter au genre de chos je pense
que oui ça nous aide à prendre plus
conscience des dangers et ça nous fait
vraiment réaliser ça fait réagir un peu
les gens quand même donc ouais moi je
suis pour sincèrement je suis pour voilà
pour ces quelques réactions concernant
la sécurité routière toujours il y a eu
ces dernières semaines des pistes qui
ont été avancé pour réduire les
accidents on peut abaisser le taux
d'alcool chez les jeunes conducteurs par
exemple de 0,5 à 02 ça ça vous plaît pas
parce que ça se stigmatise oui ça
stigmatise une population je pense qu'il
faudrait déjà faire respecter le 05 hein
parce que si vous regarderemble de pays
qui nous entourent vous avez par
exempleangleterre où on boit beaucoup
mais la seule différence en Angleterre
c'est que quand on a bu on conduit pas
donc voyez ça faut faire respecter et
donc faut une interdiction
totale oui mais il faut la faire
respecter vous savez en Russie c'est le
taux zéro je peux pas dire que c'est le
pays où on respecte mieux l'alcool est
au volant hein comment on peut faire
respecter il faut plus renforcer la
sécurité faut plus de punition ou on est
plus dans l'éducation encore une fois
sensibiliser éduquer c'est aussi un
problème de santé publique he
l'alcoolisme puisqueon s'aperçoit que
les les accidents graves ont lieu
au-delà de 1 g 20 donc c'est un un sujet
qui qui est vaste santé publique je l'ai
dit et et puis éducation dès l'école
donc c'est tout un processus long à
mettre en place mais qui vaut le coup
alors dans les Bones mesures qui
viennent aussi d'être mis en place qui
sont testé en ce moment ce sont les
tests salivaires parce que la drogue au
volance est devenu un phénomène
extrêmement important il y a 4 % des
morts par la drogue mais il y a 21 % des
des accidents mortals où on retrouve de
la drogue les test salivaair c'est le
second test en fait puisque pour
vérifier jusqu'à présent il fallait une
prise de sang après le test salivaire
pour détecter la drogue et là on teste
dans une dizaine de départements dont le
département des ivelines second test
salivè c'est en Espagne où ça se fait
déjà il a pas recours à la prise de sang
permet d'augmenter le nombre de tests
parce qu'avant effectivement ça rebutait
les forces de l'ordre d'être obligé de
d'amener à l'hôpital quelqu'un qui
fallait tester alors que là on peut le
faire immédiatement donc c'est une bonne
chose les PV à la volée aussi c'est une
bonne chose ça on n pas on nime pas trop
nous de même qu'on aaime pas trop les
radars automatiques on pr faire la
pédagogie ça veut dire les gens on faut
respecter la loi faut respecter les
vitesses faut respecter le le
stationnement mais la pédagogie c'est
mieux quand vous arrivez à avoir un PV
chez vous vous dites mais dans quelles
conditions j'ai eu ce PV qu'est-ce que
je faisais où j'étais si vous vous savez
pas c'est pas très pédagogique vous
payez mais bon c'est pas une vraie leçon
pour vous donc quand on a affaire à
l'humain c'est quand même mieux la
mission prioritaire pour 40 millions
d'automobilistes pour conclure
aujourd'hui votre chantier principal
c'est quoi benah notre chané bon il y a
il y a la sécurité routière mais aussi
le respect je dirais de des intérêts de
l'automobiliste on assiste en
particulier aujourd'hui à une espèce
d'autophobie ambiante qui n'est pas la
réalité regardez le Mondial automobile
on a battu le nombre de de
visiteurs regardez il y a un baromètre
qui est publié chaque année par la qui
parle du rapport de l'automobiliste avec
l'automobile 80 % des ruraux déclarent
que le le l'automobile est le seul moyen
efficace de se déplacer et 53 % de
urbain ils sont en augmentation de 4
points pour les ruraux et de 2 points
pour les les urbains donc ce qu'on nous
dit dans les médias souvent bobo
parisien c'est pas la réité c'est pas la
vraie vie moi je dis toujours Paris
c'est pas la France et c'est même pas
l'île- de- France à Paris on a le métro
on à les bus moi ici quand je veux faire
aller faire un débat à Paris l' jour
c'est ce que j'ai dit à France interre
je me vois mal venir par l'autor avec
mon vélo merci Daniel kerot d'être venu
jusqu'ici en voiture peut-être à 50 en
iivline pour ce journal président de 40
millions d'automobiliste merci à vous
dans l'actualité également l'incendie
d'un garage de la société d'autocar
Dominique à Buc c'est près de
guilloncour l'origine du feu n'a pas
encore été déterminé mais il semble
s'être déclaré dans la zone réservée au
branchement des bus électriques
l'ensemble du bâtiment a été détruit et
deux employés ont été légèrement blessés
lundi 20 octobre hier journée mondiale
de la douleur cette occasion nous sommes
allés à la rencontre des chirurgiens
dans les ivelines qui pratiquent des
techniques d'intervention moins
agressives moins douloureuses pour les
patients on parle de chirurgie mini
invasive elle permet aussi de réduire
les temps d'hospitalisation le reportage
lors d'une opération c'était à poissie
yolen Torz et William
l le chirurgien se prépare
l'intervention consiste ici à éliminer
les calculs réaux d'un jeune homme ces
petits cristaux contenus dans les urines
qui peuvent grossir et provoquer des
douleurs très intenses pour un homme
c'est une des douleurs les plus
importante qui peut vivre puisqu'on
comparse la douleur de la colique
néphrétique donc la maladie que cause
les calculs à la douleur d'un
accouchement sans
anesthésie pour extraire les calculs il
va utiliser une chirurgie moins
agressive dite mini invasive grâce à une
mini caméra et de la lumière qu'on peut
insérer dans le corps à l'aide de petits
tuyaux le ch chirurgien peut aller
chercher et retirer les calculs en
passant par la verge voilà donc là on
est dans le canal de
l'urêtre on fait on passe un petit coude
et on se retrouve dans la vessie voyez
j'irigue avec de l'eau lorsque les
calculs sont trop gros le chirurgien
peut même les pulvériser directement
dans le corps grâce à cette fibre laser
d'une taille minuscule de 260 microns et
le calcul vient rebondir sur la la fibre
laser et il se il se suicide quoi c'est
le l'ffet
pop-corn et à chaque à chaque fois qu'il
retouche la sonde il perd un petit grain
et nous on voit cette petite poudre
blanche àaraître
quoi quelques minutes plus tard
l'intervention est terminée les calculs
du jeune homme sont tous éliminé il va
pouvoir sortir d'ici 2 3h dans les
conditions de la chirurgie ambulatoire
moi il y a 20 ans quand je j'apprenait
la chirurgie avec mes maîtres de
chirurgie je les voyais faire prendre un
bistouri et faire une incision de 10 cm
pour des calculs que je traite
maintenant sansoir du tout à faire
d'incision quoi il y a plus du tout
d'incision donc c'est mini invasive dans
la mesure où on rentre jusqu'au bout de
l'intérieur du corps de quelqu'un mais
sans aucun dommage corporel si je peux
dire parce que l'incision ça reste un
dommage qu'on a le droit de causer au
patients la chirurgie mini invasive dont
le matériel coûte cher et nécessite de
lourds investissements et l'un des axes
majeurs de la clinique Saint-Louis à
poissis atténuer les douleurs éviter des
séjours prolongés au patients deux
atouts déjà importants pour autant
l'accompagnement post-opératoire n'est
pas à négliger il s'agit pas d'opérer la
personne de se dire voilà on est très
content on a fait une intervention min
invasive elle peut sortir derrière il
faut accompagner ce patient jusqu'à son
retour à domicile pour que lui permettre
aussi de de de maintenir une qualité de
vie et de pas l'abandonner voilà en
cours de route dans l'établissement la
chirurgie mini invasive est également
pratiquée sur le pied les hémorroïdes
à morpa pour la première fois l'ensemble
des 110 associations de la ville était
réunies lors d'une table ronde lors d'un
Grenel des association avec un objectif
leur donner les outils pour gérer le
quotidien et éviter des difficultés pour
les bénévoles Antony reche et Elodie
Moen on l'oublie trop souvent mais une
association comme un club de basket est
composé majoritairement de dirigeants
bénévoles si certaines associations
bénéficient de formation de comptabilité
ou de gestion auprès de l'Office
municipal des sports ce n'est pas le cas
de tout le monde sur ce plan là c'est
très difficile parce que il n'y a pas de
formation jusque là de au niveau
juridique ou au niveau comptabilité des
associations c'est vrai qu'une aide
serait serait importante et d'autres
associations on ont encore un besoin
plus important que que nous nous on
arrive avec les années est on arrivé à
se former
nous-même Grel des associationsis pour
la première fois par la ville de morpa
permettent aux bénévoles d'échanger sur
leurs méthodes ou leur fonctionnement
car à certaines périodes de l'année
comme lors de la rentrée être bénévole
est quasiment un travail à mi-temps on a
aussi une crise du bénévolat il est de
plus en plus compliqué de trouver des
bénévoles dans le milieu associatif et
donc il faut essayer faut essayer de
trouver des solutions pour justement
fédérer autour des associations de
nouveaux bénévoles pour qu'ils puissent
s'engager et faire vivre en tout cas le
tissu associatif morpasien c'est de plus
en de plus en plus difficile moi ça fait
une dizaine d' années que je suis dans
le
bénévola c'est vrai que ça prend
beaucoup sur la vie familial surtout
qu'on a de plus en plus de mal à trouver
des bénévoles au sein des différentes
associations les services municipaux
travaille sur un projet de création
d'une Maison des associations ainsi
qu'une charte associative la ville de
morpa comprend plus de 110 association
qui représente 7000
adhérents une dernière information avant
de se quit c'est ce soir le château de
Saint-Germain auura les honneurs du
service public France 2 et y consacre
une partie de son nouveau numéro de
secret d'histoire à 20h50 Stéphane Berne
revient en effet sur la vie du cardinal
Jules Mazarin par un du jeune Louis XIV
et puis ce mardi soir aussi mais sur TVF
78 vous avez rendez-vous avec le 78
sociétés émission débat de la rédaction
présentée ce soir par Claire Cambier
thématique du numéro les politiques
familiales je vous retrouve demain mêmes
horair pour un nouveau point complet sur
l'actualité locale du département des
ivelines bonne
soirée